imagine that  rich I make you the athletic head at one  of these local high schools and you  stand up in front of the entire school  on your first day in the job what is the  speech you give you're going to say I am  here to create in you teenagers a set of  habits around physical exercise that  will stay with you for the rest of your  life right and the tragedy is that  everybody else who gets that job says  I'm here to win as many California  titles as I can over the next five years  and we are suffering as a country as a  society as a result we look around you  one percent of the population in Middle  Ages practicing healthy habits why is  that because no one bothered to teach  them at the moment when those habits  need to be taught when it comes to  evaluating the greatness of elite  performers  we overemphasize Peak Performance and  underemphasize longevity